Speaker 1: Welcome back to The David Pakman
Show, I am Ferren cousins from Ring of Fire,
sitting in for David Pakman today.
The Dixie fire ravaging out there in the state
of California this week essentially swallowed
up an entire town, the town of Greenville.
It was an old mining town has been around
for ages.
Small population estimated to be about twelve
hundred, and that fire absolutely incinerated
and destroyed the downtown of this area.
The Dixie fire and of course, many homes and
all of that, the town is destroyed, much like
Paradise was several years ago with that wildfire.
And now we have another town that is on the
verge of not even existing because of this
fire.
Dixie Fire's been raging for three weeks now.
And it is just one of one of one of my numbers
here, one of 97 wildfires.
Currently in the United States, across 13
different states, we have 97 wildfires right
now ravaging the United States.
Twenty thousand active firefighters out there
trying to put out the flames or.
This is climate change.
Let's be honest, the heat dome that we saw
over the Pacific Northwest earlier this summer,
that's climate change.
We have such extreme temperatures over on
the west coast, the northern west coast.
That we've literally had billions of sea creatures.
That have died because of the extreme change
in the water temperature.
And to make matters worse, with the Dixie
fire and other fires, we're having another
weather event, you know, strong gusting winds,
you know, 30, 40 miles an hour, that is making
it difficult for firefighters to be able to
get there.
And, of course, it's making it easier for
the fire to spread.
And based on the reporting that I've seen,
it does appear.
That this fire, much like the one that destroyed
the town of Paradise, was possibly started
by faulty equipment from California energy
company P, G and E..
This one they're saying there, they believe
there was a branch laying on a piece of equipment
that could have sparked and then caused the
fire.
Obviously, it's a little too soon to make
bold accusations as to you know, PG&E was
definitely at fault for this.
First, we got to work on getting the flames
out.
We've got to conduct the investigations.
We've got to figure out what exactly is happening
here.
So that's what's being reported.
Again, can't necessarily make one claim one
way or another.
But what we do have to acknowledge, the claim
we can make is that extreme events like this,
all of these fires, not just the Dixie fire.
This is what climate change looks like.
We have watched all through twenty twenty
one, to be honest with you, as climate change.
Isn't knocking at our door.
It's bursting through that door and saying,
I am here.
Winter Storm Yurie in Texas, that was climate
change, saying, Here I am, look at me.
The heat dome, here I am, the fires that,
of course, result from the droughts and the
extreme heat.
I am here is what climate change is telling
us.
Now, we have an administration now that understands
this, we just went four years with an administration
that at one point had said that climate change
was a hoax by the Chinese.
And the Trump administration actively worked
to roll back environmental protections, emission
reductions, fuel efficiency, all for no other
reason than he wanted to undo parts of President
Obama's environmental legacy.
And Republicans cheered this stuff on, they
were happy about it.
Oh, boy, he's repealing the mat standard.
So there's going to be more mercury in our
air.
They were happy about these things.
But climate change is here.
I know, I know, I know, I know the study from
twenty eighteen saying we got 12 years till
the worst effects as climate change might
not just hit us, but might also become the
norm.
Well, guess what?
That was three years ago that that came out.
And we essentially had three years at that
point and two years prior to that of backpedaling
on the issue of climate change.
More emissions, even though we had the pandemic
last year, global emissions actually still
increased.
We're not getting better yet.
But we can.
There is still time and with an administration
that understands the dangers of this, have
they gone as far as I want them to on the
issue of climate change?
Absolutely not.
Like, really not even close to what needs
to happen.
But at least we're finally moving in the right
direction and you can't be upset about that,
we can be frustrated that we're not doing
everything that needs to be done yet.
And that's why we keep pushing and that's
why we keep fighting.
Here's a little bit of silver lining, though,